this is what happens when you work to
change things and
first they think you're crazy then they
fight you and then all of a sudden you
change the world this is elizabeth
holmes in 2015 forbes named her as the
youngest and wealthiest female
billionaire and she was hailed as the
next steve jobs
seven years later she's facing a maximum
sentence of 80 years in prison and
became the biggest joke in silicon
valley
back then theronos was a revolutionary
idea thought up by elizabeth holmes her
company was one of silicon valley's
unicorn startups valued at an estimated
nine billion dollars
in 2015 she was on top of the world
then it all came crashing down
the lies of theranosis technology were
exposed along with the role she played
in covering it all up she was ousted as
ceo and charged with massive fraud and
the company was forced to close its labs
and testing centers ultimately
shattering operations altogether
she has been convicted of fraud in
federal court
jurors found her guilty of three counts
of wire fraud and one count of
conspiracy to commit wire fraud
this is how she went from precious child
to ambitious stanford dropout to an
embattled startup founder convicted of
fraud
she was born on february 3rd 1984 in
washington dc her mum noel was a
congressional committee staffer and her
dad christian holmes worked for enron
before moving to government agencies
her family moved when she was young from
washington dc to houston
when she was seven she tried to invent
her own time machine filling up an
entire notebook with detailed
engineering drawings at the age of 9 she
told relatives she wanted to be a
billionaire when she grew up her
relatives described her as saying it
with the utmost seriousness and
determination
she had an intense competitive streak
from a young age she often played
monopoly with her younger brother and
cousin and she would insist on playing
until the end collecting the houses and
hotels until she won
if she was losing she would often storm
off more than once she ran directly
through a screen on the door
during high school she developed her
work ethic often staying up late to
study she quickly became a straight a
student and even started her own
business
she sold c plus plus compilers a type of
software that translates computer code
to chinese schools
she started taking mandarin lessons and
partway through high school talked her
way into being accepted by stanford
university's summer program which
culminated in a trip to beijing
inspired by her great great grandfather
christian holmes a surgeon she decided
she wanted to go into medicine but she
discovered early on that she was
terrified of needles
that was what led her to start her own
company
theranos
she went to stanford to study chemical
engineering when she was a freshman she
became a president scholar an honor
which came with a three thousand dollar
stipend to go toward a research project
she spent the summer after her freshman
year interning at the genome institute
in singapore she got the job partly
because she spoke mandarin
as a sophomore she went to one of her
professors and asked to start a company
with his blessing she founded real-time
cures
later changing the company's name to
theranos
thanks to a typo early employees
paychecks actually said real-time curses
she soon filed a patent application for
a medical device for chemical monitoring
and drug delivery a wearable device that
would administer medication monitor
patients blood and adjust the dosage as
needed
by the next semester she had dropped out
of stanford altogether and was working
on theranos in the basement of a college
house
her invention was the edison here's how
it worked
a pin prick would take a tiny sample of
blood from the patient's finger and kept
in a nanotainer the nanotainer would
then be inserted into the edison machine
for analysis and produce rapid results
for 130 tests
theranosis business model was based
around the idea that it could run blood
tests using proprietary technology that
required only a finger pinprick and a
small amount of blood
she said the tests would be able to
detect medical conditions like cancer
and high cholesterol
she started raising money for theranos
from prominent investors like oracle
founder larry ellison and tim draper
theronus raised more than 700 million
dollars she took investors money on the
condition that she wouldn't have to
reveal how theronos technology worked
plus she would have final say over
everything having to do with the company
that obsession with secrecy extended to
every aspect of theranos
for the first decade she spent building
her company theranos operated in stealth
mode
she even took three former theronis
employees to court claiming that he had
misused theranos trade secrets
her attitude towards secrecy and running
a company was borrowed from a silicon
valley hero of hers
former apple ceo steve jobs
she started dressing in black
turtlenecks like jobs decorated her
office with his favorite furniture and
like jobs never took vacations
she also put on a deep voice which may
have been part of a carefully crafted
image intended to help her fit into the
male dominated business world
she was a demanding boss and wanted her
employees to work as hard as she did
she had assistance track when employees
arrived and left each day to encourage
people to work longer hours she started
having dinner catered to the office
around 8 pm each night
shortly after she dropped out of
stanford at age 19 she began dating
theranos president and ceo sunny balwani
who was 20 years older than her
the two met during her third year in
stanford's summer mandarin program the
summer before she went to college
she was bullied by some of the other
students and barwani had come to her aid
barwani became her number two at
theranos despite having little
experience and often tracked his
employees whereabouts
they eventually broke up in spring 2016
when she pushed him out of the company
in 2008 the theranos board decided to
remove her as ceo in favor of someone
more experienced
but over the course of a two-hour
meeting she convinced them to let her
stay in charge of her company
as theranos started to rake in millions
of funding she became the subject of
media attention and acclaim in the tech
world she graced the covers of fortune
and forbes gave a ted talk and spoke on
panels with bill clinton and alibaba's
jack ma
theranos quickly began securing outside
partnerships capital blue cross and
cleveland clinic signed on to offer
theranose tests to their patients and
walgreens made a deal to open theranos
testing centers in their stores
theronus also formed a secret
partnership with safeway worth 350
million dollars
in 2011 she hired her younger brother
christian to work at theranos although
he didn't have a medical or science
background her brother spent his early
days at theranos reading about sports
online and recruiting his duke
university fraternity brothers to join
the company people dubbed his crew the
frat pack and thoroughbreds
at one point elizabeth holmes was the
world's youngest self-made female
billionaire with a net worth of around
4.5 billion dollars
her company was valued at 10 billion at
its peak in 2013 and 2014.
she was obsessed with security at
theranos she asked anyone who visited
the company's headquarters to sign
non-disclosure agreements before being
allowed in the building and had security
guards escort visitors everywhere even
to the bathroom
around the same time questions were
being raised about theranosis technology
ian gibbons chief scientist at theronus
and one of the company's first hires
warned her that the tests weren't ready
for the public to take and that there
were inaccuracies in the technology
outside scientists began voicing their
concerns about theronos too
by august 2015 the fda began
investigating theranos and regulators
from the government body that overseas
laboratories found major inaccuracies in
the testing theronus was doing on
patients
by october 2015 wall street journal
reporter john kerry rue published
investigation into theranos's struggles
with its technology
his reporting sparked the beginning of
the company's downward spiral he found
that theronis's blood testing machine
named edison couldn't give accurate
results
what theranos did was instead of running
the blood test through their own machine
they ran the blood test through the same
machines used by traditional blood
testing companies and told everyone that
their own machine produced the results
holmes appeared on cnbc's mad money
shortly after the wall street journal
published its story to defend herself
and theronos in july 2016 she was banned
from the lab testing industry for two
years by october theronos had shut down
its lab operations and wellness centers
in march 2018 theronos holmes and bowani
were charged with massive fraud by the
sec
she agreed to give up financial and
voting control of the company pay a five
hundred thousand dollar fine and return
18.9 million shares of theranos stock
she also isn't allowed to be the
director or officer of a publicly traded
company for 10 years
despite the charges she was allowed to
stay on as ceo of theranos
since it's a private company
the company had been hanging on by a
thread and she wrote to investors asking
for more money to save theranos
in theranos's final days she reportedly
got a siberian husky puppy named balto
that she brought into the office
however the dog wasn't potty trained and
would go to the bathroom inside the
company's office and during meetings
in june 2018 theronus announced that
holmes was stepping down as ceo on the
same day the department of justice
announced that a federal grand jury had
charged holmes along with bahwani with
nine counts of wire fraud and two counts
of conspiracy to commit wire fraud
theranos sent an email to shareholders
in september 2018 announcing that the
company was shutting down theranos
reportedly said it planned to spend the
next few months repaying creditors with
its remaining resources
besides the criminal case she was also
involved in a number of civil lawsuits
including one in arizona brought by
former theronus patients over inaccurate
blood tests
the lawyers representing her in the
arizona case said in late 2019 they
hadn't been paid in over a year and
asked to be removed from her legal team
the trial kicked off in september 2021
on the stand holmes said balwani
emotionally and sexually abused her
during their relationship
she also admitted that she added some
pharmaceutical companies logos without
authorization
investors previously said they took some
reassurance in those reports because
based on the logos they thought major
pharmaceutical companies had validated
theranos's technology she said she added
the logos to convey that work was done
in partnership with those companies but
in hindsight she wishes she had done it
differently
she also acknowledged on the stand that
she hid theronos's use of modified
commercial devices from investors she
said she did this because company
council told her that alterations the
company made to the machines were trade
secrets and needed to be protected as
such in closing arguments prosecutors
argued that holmes chose fraud over
business failure while the defense
argued she was building a business not a
criminal enterprise
after 15 weeks of trial the jury
returned a mixed verdict for holmes
finding her guilty on one count of
conspiracy to defraud investors and
three counts of wire fraud they found
her not guilty on four other counts and
failed to reach a verdict on the
remaining three counts
the counts holmes was found guilty of
were all related to investments
she wasn't convicted on any of the
charges involving patients who received
inaccurate test results
she now faces the possibility of 80
years in prison with each count carrying
a maximum 20-year prison sentence a 250
000 fine and a requirement to pay a
victim's restitution
she went from the world's youngest
self-made female billionaire with a net
worth of around 4.5 billion to facing
the possibility of 80 years in prison
what can we learn from her fall from
grace well in short she took thomas
edison's quote too seriously i didn't
fail 1000 times the light bulb was an
invention with 1 000 steps
the technology required for invention
simply was not there yet
sometimes you can be so fixated on your
dream that you'll stop at nothing to
achieve it
for holmes she started her business with
good intentions she set out to
revolutionize the industry to make
medical testing more efficient more
convenient and less painful however she
simply would not give up on her dream
and just covered the inadequacies of her
invention with a mountain of lies
her determination eventually became
delusion
thanks for staying till the end of this
video if you enjoyed this video then be
sure to hit the like button drop a
comment subscribe and hit the
notification bell for more content like
this also be sure to check out our other
videos on this channel links are in the
description and we'll see you in the
next one